fun fact in senegal
the language is wolof the main language
is wolof
and in wolof when you say moose
that means cat that's one of the few
wool off words that i know
okay i think i'm aborting the the moose
um okay we'll move on i have 101 pending
challenges
oh never played canadian syrup from
canada
username matches a country
good luck to my opponent oh thank you
chad
also ordering merch yeah a lot of orders
in the last like
20 minutes of white moves first okay
i'll play english
i'll play uh i might play a vampire
someone mentioned the vampire earlier
where
you have fangs and you try and bite the
opponent
that's almost mate thankfully i have g3
oh oh no black's queen
bishop e2 is such a funny move to
pre-move too
[Music]
wow i feel inspired
i feel like some people would
impulsively take thinking black just
mouse slipped
but then takes his mate so let's not
take a queen
develop and and uh
win some material
yeah this is uh the most effective way
to bite
the queen was basically what's what
what's the poison for vampires is it
garlic
or daylight when playing viewers is it
expected that they should leave or mute
the stream when playing you
oh that's a fair question i actually
don't mind either way
i usually make the assumption my point
could be watching
so if it's some like complicated
position
if it's some complicated position i'll
try not to give away too much
like here like this position
i wasn't going to mention that black has
the move queen f4 which is actually
really crazy
um now i can mention it because now it's
it's too late for black
queen f4 i wouldn't be able to take
because bishop h4 would still be mate
um
i guess i'll take what is this
i take here the queen can take and hit
my rook
i call this the rosen gambit that's
where i sacrifice a few bucks but in the
long run i
get to watch great and instructive
content from a very chill chess wizard
that's
wholesome so i clearly come out ahead
thanks for all you do man oh i
appreciate the support
classic winger i wasn't sure where that
was going but uh
yeah thanks for the the five dollars
um yeah merch does ship internationally
say maybe more than half the orders are
are international
okay i won connect for vampire
is beginning to bite
black wait was the journey of black's
queen
here here here
black probably wants to like hurt my
king
the thing is i can i could counter
attack
i couldn't find caddo do this
it's actually funny i'm just thinking
like this idea
of queen h4 and pre-moving bishop e7
this could be played in like other types
of openings
i'll probably share after this game
making me think of an opening trap i've
never even considered before
uh i'll play queen d3
have to name this a canadian syrup
attack
a syrup is another thing i just haven't
haven't had in a while because i'm not
really i don't really eat
waffles or pancakes
on any sort of regular basis
which means i don't really consume syrup
my favorite breakfast is avocado toast
yeah french toast is another yes europe
go canadian syrup
syrup uh requiring food
okay let's get the king to safety
it's very pleasant both bishops are
happy pawns are happy
and with castling i unpin the knight so
i want to play knight
d5 and do things keep biting
do they call french toast in france what
toast
ha ha
but what do they call french bread in
france
probably just bread or baguette
okay i guess i play knight d5 here
leaving the battery staring into empty
space
pain or pan
i actually i've never really learned
french words
chap probably knows more french than me
okay so i'm attacking this
pressuring b7
[Music]
i feel like there's a high probability
my opponent's gonna
lose some kind of material but it's
still interesting
french toast in french is payne peardy
which literally translates to lost bread
really oh
because when you make the french toast
you lose the essence of bread
but you gain the essence of toast
ah now i'm hungry
thankfully the night will satisfy my
hunger
for the time being
man the merch orders keep going mortal
womprat thanks for
the yummy yummy etc
uh okay um
i am still hungry
play rook
only up pawn play this move
realizing this rook should stay aligned
with
the other things this is only halfway
vial for white
oh did levy show this opening trap
that's another thing chat would know
better than me
chat knows french word and cuisine
better than me
and levy's content um
so maybe this is like vampire opening
theory
b6 hard to stop bishop c5 mr rose
now you will hear what i have to say to
you oh dear thanks for everything we
love you
i love you too jimberwood appreciate
that
that was i was scared after the first
part of the
that sentence but i appreciate the kind
words
okay so i want to trap the queen
maybe like in the event of bishop here i
take actually i probably just want to
meet the king
but canadian syrup is resisting thank
you
tommy triathlete
something for foreign it is called lost
bread because traditionally stale bread
was used to make the french toast
really wait but french toast is like
really soft
so i wouldn't think it would be made
from stale bread
but maybe like when you make it
how do you make french toast like you
put it in the frying pan right
you add some eggs and oil etc or butter
i don't think i've ever actually like
made french toast
i've probably ordered it a few times
also look at these pawns
pawns are really uh enjoying the center
very tetris-like let's keep pushing
oh but if i push i get forked
i have to do this
could be patient
if i play this move this is probably the
way to go
and then win this pawn and then go in
for the kill
stale bread soaks up the mixture better
eggs plus milk soak the bread and fry
oh i'm learning so much
about french words and french toast
maybe i'll do a cooking stream or i just
make things that
chat chat tells me to make
you can give me all the cooking
instructions queen b6 is a good move
i'm gonna um make a battery
try and win the pawn b4 may be coming
just realize the queen could deliver a
check
oh if i play b4 it takes and i lose my
queen
okay let's play h3 my king will hide
it'll be cool to do a cooking stream but
i would need to like move the stream
setup into the kitchen
which actually shouldn't be too
difficult
would eric five years ago ever imagine
being a chess celebrity
i don't think that term existed five
years ago
unless you were like magnus or
fisher or kasparov
my tetris structure is still existing
and black's fending off things
relatively well
yeah i still want to push pawns it would
be nice to
make some french toast with some
canadian maple syrup
and some eggs
oh thanks for the words little mo with
[ __ ]
welcome to twitch yeah if you're new
here this is twitch
this is chess uh sometimes
easy to get off topic but uh
trying to play some decent moves i think
we might have to trade queens
i can play this move too
[Music]
just creating the battery
there is increments so my opponent could
survive it has to move quickly
by each four
okay there there is a possibility of on
passant mate
but it's still kind of far away let's
play b4
how to do this
um play this move
okay so i lost material a little bit
take with rook
i actually i see the um
i'm seeing the possibility now
i don't want black to resign
get ready for it don't resign canadian
syrup
get ready for it
a second time don't resign
don't do it
you have one legal move
on poissonmate let's go
i saw it from pretty far away too
well again i'm gonna have to put that
whole thing on youtube now
that's such a random discussion of toast
and french bread
let's go second time ever
anarchy chess will be pleased
slow motion replay
i don't mean to rub it in except that's
kind of what you're supposed to do to
syrup
right to spread the flavor
i think i speak for the chat when i say
let's go and poss on teammate ftw
oh yeah on passantmate for the win
what was this oh this was uh um
[Music]
i forgot this was like the weird opening
too
[Music]
and it's lagging because lee just can't
handle the fact that
i had on poisson mate
um
yeah this opening was really cool queen
h4 bishop e7
it's really cool to pre-move this too
yeah i learned something new
the vampire um
the thought i had i just wanted to share
this if
white plays a bird which is a slightly
more common opening than the vampire
and then black plays the froms gambit
then after takes you can play the same
trap queen h4
and pre-move bishop e7 more satisfying
becoming and i am more on pass on mate
on to son mates by far
anyway here you pre-move bishop e7 and
then say oh no my queen
that sequence will need to be called the
french toast mate
oh oh cause we were yeah on poisson is
um
like on croissant or
on how do you say french toast in french
something pain anyway um
yeah oh no my queen and then mate so how
many people walked into this one
oh bishop e7 the second most played move
oh so hundreds of people already know
this one
no one's ever taken the queen
wow that's impressive
so there's a zero percent success rate
with this trap
i should show in our game
um after knight of three i thought i was
just winning a pawn
but black could take and then again say
oh no
my queen and if i take there's mate
so that's a weird game
i feel like the whole game i was just
kind of memeing but
yeah this is the ultimate meme on
facademate